the police reporter eight news now
investigators obtained Witnesses
describe the brutal attacks that's right
well some of the victims knew something
wasn't right when Barrios approached
them Madison Kimbrough joins us live
from the area where the incident
happened and shares what these victims
went through Madison
yeah this area around win is exactly
where the stabbing took place now
Witnesses say the Barrios started
running and then looking for groups of
people so he could quote let out his
anger
in the police report Witnesses and those
injured recall what they saw as
32-year-old Yani Barrios made his way
through the crowd Thursday just before
noon while the name of the injured have
not been released one witness states
that Barrios approached a group of
Showgirls near the main entrance of the
wind he had a set of knives on him and
asked the Showgirls to take a picture
with him and the knives and that's when
things escalated a witness states that
one of the women started to feel
uncomfortable and began to back away at
which point Barrios charged at her as
she started to run away that woman fell
to the ground Barrios could be seen
charging at 30 year old showgirl Maris
de Giovanni next she died of her
injuries then he ran off stabbing
47-year-old Brent Hallett in the back
pallet died on scene another witness
recalls Barrios running towards him
holding quote a large kitchen knife
covered in blood that knife was later
located by police in the bushes
described as a gray 12-inch chef knife
with a black handle that witness also
saying that Barrios ran past him and
said sorry man before stabbing him in
the middle of the back thus that witness
quote fell to the ground and screamed
for help as his wife applied pressure to
his wound and shortly after police
arrived
one of the victims also told police that
he was on sands Avenue talking on the
phone when a man with an object ran
towards him he then thought he was
punched in the chest and then saw blood
now I did reach out to Marist
digiovanni's family she said in this
statement that we have Graphics up you
can see quote Maris loved the beauty of
life and lived it to the fullest without
limitations she was a beautiful spirit
and soul and we will miss her for the
rest of our lives
I've seen so many stories of survival
for these victims and we do know that
there are six recovering is there any
update on their injuries
yeah according to UMC we have one
patient in critical condition one in
Fair now two others were released and
two others taken to Sunrise both in Fair
and good conditions Christian reporting
live Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now